في السودان ايضا عائلاتهم تنتظر خبرا او
ما يدل عن حياه المفقودون خلال الاقتتال
والذين فاق عددهم المئتين هؤلاء اختفى
اثرهم بقيت صورهم التي ينشرها اقاربهم كل
حين على مواقع التواصل لعلهم يجدون مخبرا
عضو لجنه تنسيقيه لمبادره مفقود ساره
حمدان اكدت ان عدد المدنيين بين المفقودين
فاقل 198 شخصا عاد منهم 25 فقط الى ذويهم
فيما تم العثور على خمس جثث اوضحتا غالبيه
العظمى من المفقودين تتراوح اعمارهم بين
25 و 30 عاما بينهم محمد مروان او العريس
المفترض الذي اختفى قبل زفافه المقرر في
الثالث عشر من مايو محمد اختفى بظروف
غامضه في اول يوم من المواجهات اتصال
هاتفي اخير اجراه مع خطيبته قبل التحرك
لاخذها من مستشفى السلاح الطبي العسكري
بام درمان حيث تعمل انتظرته طويلا ولم
ياتيه وفقد اثره منذ ذلك الحين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات